[Music]
my Jenny was a bit tough the economy was
very bad in snubbull no jobs companies
they were closing so I decided to come
into South Africa looking for work
[Music]
my first chance was operating a forklift
because that was the only available
option I had previous experience from
warm then I had some experience
well the mechanical is just a little bit
I could do all sort of small jobs so
they realized as time went on that this
guy can easily adapt now I'm a Pecos
manager for the tomato pickers and the
banana pick house I would say maybe
Agriculture's one of the sector where
it's had people from neighboring
countries to come for employment with
other places to find a job is very
difficult so people will migrate with
this area because they want to get
better life for their families they want
at least to get employment Africa is the
youngest continent full of energy but at
the same time is a continent with an
enormous unemployment every year we
would need to be generating 12 to 13
million of job for the new entrants into
the market economy and Africa only
generates 3 million this is again why I
believe sustainable agriculture and
limit smart agriculture and rural areas
play a crucial role agriculture is I
think it gives more jobs than any other
jobs and people adapt easier to
agriculture you see they learn quickly
because it's there even in the rules if
there are homes people still practice
agriculture it at small bases most of
the times they already know they work
but they need to adapt a little bit to
the circumstances of the hosting country
capacity-building rates immediate
benefits and a win-win situation both
for migrants and for the hosting
communities doesn't matter the girl
black or white or ever to studying the
farm because that's where there is an
economy if you found then you're
creating major opportunities for other
people as well and then there is a
program from the government that people
must that be must be sent to other
able to farm and all the days why we are
now even giving a University of Milan so
there is a need for us we keep on
training people to be farmers
one of the strengths is to provide the
adequate skills to migrants or non
migrants to rural communities in order
to make agriculture modern they need to
to learn new agricultural techniques
they need to learn how to strain the
value change of Agriculture that goes
from the harvesting and the consumer so
to reinforce agribusiness to reinforce
harvesting transportation market
opportunities we bring them to the land
we started working with them with some
time to refer to let them work May 4
2007 with method working by my hands
myself then I was then a foreman
supervisor managed and then now I'm
happy to be production manager if if
good potential they give you space they
try to teach you so after a long term
somebody decides to go back there with a
lot of work experience we do train them
to become farmers because we believe if
we empower them then you will be
empowering the nation
a big issue for us is that rural areas
have been neglected and that youth live
in rural areas a growing population in
Africa that is supposed to double by
2050 and that's why we're working
constantly to make agriculture
attractive to connect agriculture with
rural and urban linkages to make
agriculture part of the value chain to
make subsistence agriculture closer to
agribusiness to bring innovation to
bring ideas and successes stories so
other youth when watching the neighbor
succeeding can also replicate with a
good example when I came from to be
frank I was just an ordinary guy but for
now I have learned a lot I've got the 16
year old boy who is in Zimbabwe I send
money every time there I - after three
months for food for school fees
everything you'll be going to university
I'm not worried about paying for you
I'll be able to do so so it changes
somebody's lives
you
[Music]